bon ceci étant dit pour retrouver les
premiers écrits qui commence à rendre
compte des formes d'organisations du
monde social il faut augmenter 2500 ans
en arrière à peu près donc bon vous vous
y attendez peut-être en remontant de
1500 ans en arrière nous nous trouvons
en grèce antique et avec notamment
platon qui dans son ouvrage intitulé la
république a déjà commencé à étudier
comment les humains vivent en société
ils commencent d'ailleurs à étudier la
division du travail et l'interdépendance
que celle ci crée entre les individus
qui vivent dans une même communauté
une question qui est toujours
d'actualité aujourd'hui
après ça reste difficile de voir
vraiment de la sociologie là dedans
parce qu en fait ce que fait platon
c'est de proposer un modèle de société
qui serait parfait et c'est en fait
exactement l'inversé de ce que fait le
sociologue qui ne donne aucun conseil
qu'ils n'étaient qu observer la société
telle qu'elle est réellement
alors que platon fait plutôt des
conseils de la société qu'elle telle
qu'elle devrait être moins et après l'un
des plus grands philosophes qui
réfléchit à la question c'est l'un des
élèves de platon que vous connaissez
sûrement aristote
alors oui je sais que aristote a la
réputation d'être un peu en manche quand
il vient à parler des règles de la
nature mais c'était plutôt un génie
quand ils en arrivaient à parler des
organisations humaines sociales et
politiques de façon générale par exemple
il va contre avec platon qui essayait de
définir le meilleur modèle de société
qu'il faudrait amener à créer en disant
que de toute façon on ne peut pas créer
une société puisque la société précède
nécessairement l'homme il dit que la
société ait nécessairement antérieure
aux individus puisque chacun isolément
ne peut se suffire à lui même et c'est à
partir de là qu'il va définir l'homme
comme un animal sortir votre attention
sur le fait que timo logiquement le mot
politique ça vient du mot grec police
qui signifie la cité état on étudie donc
l'organisation sociale à l'échelle d'une
ville est déjà à l'époque il pointe du
doigt les problèmes qui pourraient
survenir à une société qui laisserait
croître trop d'inégalités et qui serait
alors voués à une instabilité chronique
il fait d'ailleurs une typologie des
différents régimes politiques possibles
à savoir monarchie aristocratie
démocratie et leurs dérives éventuelles
en cas de d'instabilité chronique à
savoir tyrannie oligarchie ou démagogie
pas si à côté de la plaque que ça le
père brixton
après on va faire un petit saut dans le
temps je vais pas énumérer tous les
travaux car elle peut servir de base à
la sociologie parce que bon sinon ce
sera un petit peu long et fastidieux le
plus souvent ça va être des travaux de
philosophie plus précisément de
philosophie politique
je peux vous en citer 42 pour faire vite
on va avoir le léviathan de hobbes en
1651 ou le contrat social de rousseau en
1762 on n'a pas encore vraiment de
grands ouvrages philosophiques qui nous
parle de la société de comment l'homme
évolue en société de comment se font les
interactions sociales
là c'est plutôt comment s'organiser
l'activité politique de façon générale
et on arrive au 19e siècle
c'est là qu'il ya des choses un petit
peu qu'ils commencent à se passer en
termes d'analysé sociologique
on a de plus en plus envie de savoir
comment évoluent les hommes en société
et s'est grandement lié à l'apparition
de la question sociale mais qui n'est
d'abord pas pris en compte par les
scientifiques
oui alors le problème n'est pas pris en
compte par les scientifiques mais je
vous rappelle qu'on a eu une époque où
la sociologie n'existe pas en tant que
science institutionnalisée et on est
surtout à une époque le dix neuvième
siècle ou qui a vu la naissance de ce
qu'on a appelé les intellectuels alors
les intellectuels ils sont à la fois
philosophe mathématicien philologue n'y
a pas encore vraiment de cloisonnement
entre les différentes disciplines et du
coup les premiers qui vont faire des
travaux réellement représentatifs et
explicative de comment se déplo
l'activité humaine bain paradoxalement
ça va être des artistes et plus
spécifiquement des romanciers le
sociologue comme l'artiste s'intéresse à
des problèmes qui lui sont contemporains
et il n'est donc pas étonnant que l'on
voit apparaître d'abord chez les
romanciers des questionnements sur leur
société en pleine mutation
on voit par exemple qu'au 19e siècle
l'essor de la misère ouvrière suscite de
nombreuses réactions et notamment sur le
plan littéraire les misérables de victor
hugo qui varie en 1862 se déroule sous
la restauration de la monarchie de
juillet à des moments où la question
sociale apparaît avec force
l'ambition de balzac par exemple à
travers le projet de la comédie humaine
dans laquelle il se considère lui-même
comme le secrétaire de la société
contemporaine et de décrire les espèces
social avec une méthode presque
scientifique semblable à la façon dont
on recensait les espèces naturelles et
le projet le plus clair dans ce sens
c'est sans doute l'oeuvre complète
d'emile zola qui par sa série de romans
les rougon-macquart sept signes comme
projet de décrire les moeurs de ses
contemporains oui d'ailleurs je précise
qu'on dit tout le temps les
rougon-macquart pour faire plus court et
que le titre originel de la fois d'emile
zola c'est rougon macquart histoires
naturelles et sociales d'une famille
sous le second empire
cette plate déjà un peu mieux l'ambition
du gaillacois bien sûr il s'agit là d'
oeuvre de fiction mais zola est
notamment connu pour les kilomètres de
notes qu'il prenait et les
renseignements très minutieux qu'il
engrangeait avant d'écrire
afin de coller au réel de la façon la
plus satisfaisante possible
il est d'ailleurs le chef de file du
mouvement littéraire des naturalistes
qui est originellement un terme
scientifique et qui signifie qu'ils
essaient
la fiction de s'approcher le plus
possible d'une méthode scientifique de
description du réel et c'est également à
cette période à la fin du 19e siècle que
la sociologie commence à
s'institutionnaliser sur le plan
scientifique et ça nous permet de
comprendre pourquoi on a encore parfois
aujourd'hui du mal à considérer la
sociologie comme une véritable science
parce qu'elle est issue de ce qu'on a
appelé la troisième culture et qui se
fraye péniblement un chemin entre la
littérature d'un côté et la science de
l'autre le terme de sociologie va
apparaître pour la première fois au
milieu du xixème siècle par le
scientifique
auguste comte qui est un positivisme a
très rapidement les positivistes c'est
ce qu'ils pensent que la sociologie les
sciences humaines de façon générale
peuvent acquérir le même degré mme de
scientificité que les sciences dures et
que à terme elles pourront montrer le
vrai avec autant de certitude que la
physique ou les mathématiques
une chose qui me semble très importante
c'est que l'intronisation de la
sociologie sur le plan universitaire n'a
pas pu se faire sans une cassure très
nette d'avec ses racines littéraire donc
on avait d'un côté la littérature et de
l'autre la sociologie et cela a eu aussi
un impact très important sur la
littérature elle-même comme je le dis au
cours du xixème siècle les romanciers se
sont assez largement fait les analystes
du monde social mais une fois la
sociologie créé cette analyse dépendait
maintenant des scientifiques et plus des
artistes
les artistes se sont donc trouvés
dépourvus de cette analyse là on peut
faire exactement le même parallèle avec
le monde de la peinture
pendant des années les peintres ont été
les seuls capables de rendre compte du
monde réel et ont essayé de peindre le
réel avec le plus de réalisme possible
par exemple quand on veut riche voulait
se faire tirer le portrait ben ils se
faisaient prendre par un peintre il
payait sa fourchette
mais ça lui permettait d'avoir une
représentation de lui qu'ils pouvaient
approcher partout il voulait une fois la
développement de la photographie
les gens ont bien tenant pu se faire
photographier et il n'était plus
nécessaire d'avoir un peintre pour
rendre compte du réel
petit à petit les peintres ont donc pu
se détacher de l'obligation obligations
entre guillemets de représenter le réel
et ça a permis aussi de faire naître de
nouveaux courants comme l'abstraction
c'est donc au début du 20e siècle qu'on
a pu voir de plus en plus de détachement
des romanciers vis-à-vis de la réalité
avec l'avènement du nouveau roman et
puis assez rapidement des surréalistes
alors évidemment je suis pas en train de
dire que c'est l'avènement de la
sociologie uniquement qui a créé la
révolution des courants artistiques
évidemment pas puisque de toute façon ce
sont des modes de pensée et d évolution
beaucoup plus globale qui se passe dans
tous les arts de façon générale et pas
uniquement en littérature mais il est
quand même intéressant de voir que
l'avènement de la sociologie est
sûrement l'un des éléments qui a permis
l'avènement de ces nouveaux courants
littéraires
voilà mais maintenant qu'on a dit tout
ça je vais en arriver à ce que je veux
vraiment vous dire dans cet épisode
d'introduction déjà je commençais par
nuancer mon propos en disant que ce
n'est pas parce qu'une oeuvre n'est pas
réaliste qu'elle ne parle pas quand même
deux réalités sociales à toutes les
époques les artistes ont toujours parlé
à travers leurs oeuvres de la société
qu'il arrêtait contemporaine que ces
oeuvres soient réalistes ou non on
pouvait toujours en déduire un message
ou en propos sur la société
ce n'est pas parce que l'avènement de la
sociologie aurait permis une certaine
déconnexion entre les mondes de l'art et
les réalités sociales qu'il faut les
maintenir déconnectée parce que c'est
justement ce que je me propose de faire
à travers cette émission analyser des
oeuvres fictionnel et voir ce que ces
heures peuvent nous dire sur la société
contemporaine
voilà j'ai pas encore vraiment parlé d'
oeuvre de fiction ici parce que c'est
vraiment là un épisode d'introduction
j'essaie de vous montrer un petit peu ce
que c'est que mon projet mais il ya le
deuxième épisode de sociologie qui va
bientôt arriver où on nous parlerons de
matrix comme je vous invite grandement
vous abonner à la chaîne ça vous a
intéressé et que vous voulez sur un
petit peu les nouvelles publications
et puis en attendant moi je vous dis pas
la prochaine et qu'aristote veille sur
votre politeia à l'école
oui je voulais juste rajouter que pour
ceux qui valait encore un petit peu plus
loin je vais mettre plein de liens dans
la description que je vous invite à
cliquer c'est que des trucs vachement
intéressant et puis je me suis aperçu
que j'avais aussi pas répondu à la
question donc allons-y
évidemment il faut une barbe je viens de
président